parce que ya 19 ans et je suis
souverainiste
gaëlle berger beaugier 19 ans un des six
jean philippe côté 20 ans fédéraliste
fait l'expert no 17 a souverainiste
ambivalent
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs c'est la
tête haute au monde seule je te coller
devant la télévision
c'est une soirée qui était
incontournable en 1981 sylvain gauthier
avait 20 ans ils votaient pour la
première fois de sa vie
ce que je trouvais ce nom c'était qu'on
avait l'impression de faire l'histoire
avec un espoir de créer quelque chose de
nouveau quelque chose de meilleur parce
que nous eh ben on va faire du québec le
pays la tendance des résultats
recueillis depuis quelques minutes par
radio-canada les war que l'option du non
l'emporterait le 20 mai au soir c'était
il y avait une atmosphère qui était dit
c'est le nous de voir monsieur les vins
qui arrivait sur la scène et avait
l'image de notre saison mais c'est un
lieu où c'était quelqu'un qui s'était
investi corps et âme à la cause en 1981
plus de 60% des jeunes ont voté oui le
fait savoir qu'il y avait des milliers
des milliers de gens qui pensaient comme
nous qu'ils étaient prêts à s'investir
dans la création d'un pays qui nous
ressemble qui nous rassemble mais ça je
trouvais ça merveilleux si je vous ai
bien compris vous êtes en train de dire
à la prochaine fois
aujourd'hui les moins de 35 ans sont
moins souverainiste que leurs aînés on
s'est affirmée le québec a pris sa place
les francophones beaucoup ont repris
leur place qu'il des fois on l'a on les
empêchait d'accéder à certains postes
donc là la situation changer le contexte
est très différent
donc c'est sûr que la mobilisation était
très différente aujourd'hui une question
à savoir si les femmes et beck un pays
sylvie gautier devait aller en droit
mais la fébrilité et la puissance du
débat de l'époque l'ont fait bifurquer
vers la science politique il enseigne
depuis 30 ans dans sa classe il a vu la
fièvre souverainiste s'essouffler c'est
un moment ration de vue ce village de ya
peu de cours qui vont traiter de la
question québécoise sentiment
identitaire y a plus de cours d'histoire
du québec
y a plus de cours de politique sur le
québec proprement dit et la maintenance
est vraiment internationale enfin on va
aller sur l'a3 aujourd'hui un sujet
chaud pour vous le groupe armé état
islamique
même constat ici au collège édouard
montpetit à longueuil l'environnement et
l'international ont pris le dessus sur
la question nationale avant le
référendum à 80 vous l'avez dit
vous-même le quotidien c'était pour la
souveraineté maintenant un mouvement
étudiant c'est pas pour la souveraineté
on n'en parlera pas vraiment parlé on
veut un pays parce que c'est un rêve
parce que mes grands-mères l'emporter ou
pour moi c'est pas assez
gaëlle berger vosges il se sentait
souverainiste et québécoises d'abord
jusqu'à ce qu'elle aille à l'étranger
nous est tellement canadienne
je sais pas c'est quoi ça fait que ça
veut dire tellement canadienne mais
pourtant une des armes c'est parce que
tu police parce que t es malade et
souriante
pour moi ça a été vraiment un choc parce
que à ce moment là je me suis rendu
compte que j'avais aucune idée c'est
quoi le reste du canada
je me soucie pas du peuple québécois
mais je me dis est ce qu on fait fausse
route en mettant l'accent seulement sur
le fait qu'on veut donner un pays mais
dans faut qu'on n'a pas d'objectif clair
de mentionner que il fallait de quoi de
plus concret que juste vouloir faire un
pays mais je sais pas ce qui est plus
concret que défendre
un enjeu qui était absent en 1981 est
devenu incontournable pour les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui
le territoire à reconnaître aux peuples
autochtones dans un éventuel québec
s'ouvre est comment on va s'arranger
pour les accommoder est ce qu'on va leur
donner du territoire puis on garde les
barrages parce que certaines zones tout
est ce qu'on leur donne des territoires
qui ont laissé barrage très bonne
remarque si on fais pas aux autres ce
qu'on veut pas se faire fin donc pour ce
jeu
ce qui ne veut pas dire s'il faut faire
quelque chose il faut pas le faire ça
fait partie du débat mais le simple fait
de parler de ce débat la sarre et anime
la flamme moi j'ai toujours eu cette
tendance-là vouloir être pour la
souveraineté à vouloir c'est cet
idéalisme locon qu'on pourrait essayer
quelque chose de nouveau c'est qu'on
pourrait juste se jeter dans le vide
tous ensemble puis essayer de voir ce
que ça donnerait filet que se référant à
des crocs et les vins qu'en 1981 avec
jacques parizeau et lucien bouchard
aussi en 1995 mais il ne suivrait pas un
leader comme pierre karl péladeau perçu
trop à droite par ces jeunes je sais pas
si je serai prêt justement à suivre
quelqu'un qui amène le québec dans une
direction que moi je suis prêt pas prêt
à suivre même si c'est signifie d'avoir
de devenir un pays souverain maintenant
péladeau sa présence à ces messieurs
mais si le lock-out du journal de
montréal ne faut pas oublier seul sait
quand même est-ce que c'est le genre de
personne qu'on veut suivre si lequel son
indépendance donc québec ces jeunes
reste il de vivre dans 35 ans un québec
qui se reconnaît un québec qui a proper
de prendre des réussites on soit cuit ou
qu'on soit une province encore et
personnellement j'aimerais ça qu'on est
de plus en plus de maisons sociales
quitte à payer plus de taxes
mais qui prend exemple sur un pays
scandinaves la norvège
moi j'espère vraiment vivre dans un
québec souverain je trouve que c'est un
idéal qui est à notre portée